chuck i'm going to talk about space
telescopes
see you later
oh [ __ ] your ass now okay
all right if you must uh here's how it
goes
so i i think many people don't know that
the telescope and the microscope
were both discovered within 10 years of
each other
arguably the two most potent tools in
the scientist arsenal yeah
are those two instruments one going out
and one going in the large and the small
right that's right that's right
and uh before galileo first looked up
that it existed but they didn't call it
a telescope don't they call it
uh spyglass oh okay that makes sense
just a spyglass yes uh clearly galileo
was just the first guy to see an
academic
application exactly that's all he was
like
why is everybody looking this way
yeah exactly right exactly so
that telescope was of a refracting
variety so it has a lens
at one end and then at the other end you
have like an eyepiece right
and the light comes through that piece
of glass and then it
focuses down to a point that gets
magnified by the eyepiece and you see an
image that's very cool that is cool okay
so but there's a problem with that kind
of telescope interestingly
because okay if you made a shape of a
lens with your it's like this right
right right okay right a convex lens
looks like this
well that kind of resembles two prisms
attached to each other okay at their
base but one upside down and one right
side up okay so think about it
when light comes through a prism you've
seen the cover of
pink floyd's dark side of the moon the
light comes through
and it spreads into its colors right so
if a convex lens is sort of like two
prisms
that tells you what is happening
through that convex lens because the
light comes through
the bottom lens the bottom half of the
lens is like an upside down
prism that'll spread light into into its
colors the upper one will spread light
into into its colors
so the red the green the yellow the blue
all focus at a different place
so you can see an image but it's like a
rainbow
around the image right it's called
chromatic aberration that's what it's
called
that sounds cool
i actually i know it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing not a good thing
i mean what a don't give bad things good
names
traumatic aberrations have you been
chromatically aberrated
right right i'll take that so so
it still worked as a telescope but it
was not ideal
and it would take another hundred years
before my man
oh don't say let me see i uh your body
my man the isaac newton isaac who do you
think my man was i don't know
all right thank you yeah so isaac newton
said i can fix that
let's not use a lens let's use a mirror
so he takes a curved mirror
the light comes in it comes to a focus
just like it did through the lens
except all all colors of light
reflect at exactly the same angle and
solve the chromatic aberration problem
you know the more you tell me about this
newton guy the more i'm starting to
think he was really smart plus
he's not this newton guy he's newton yes
that's true
yeah it's not like this guy joey no he
is newton
right this is true okay right and i call
him ike you call him
isaac newton he's ike to me all right
all right all right i'm just saying
so he so he invented this new kind of
telescope a reflecting telescope
reflecting all telescopes today are
reflecting telescopes yeah and this man
set that into motion that's right so now
so now we got a good telescope in the
house okay all right
so now what next so you look up
to the night sky and it's it's beautiful
it's beautiful yes it's beautiful
problem is we're looking through an
atmosphere right so obviously you don't
want to look when they're clouds
but even a clear sky there's turbulence
in the clear air okay you know what it's
like have you ever been on a hot day and
you look on the surface of the pavement
and you see the image kind of undulates
that's where you get mirage
yes it's like water it looks like water
right that
movement of the air preventing you from
see a clear image
that's happening in every direction you
look in the sky wow because different
pockets of the atmosphere
undulate at different temperatures okay
and so the light is coming through and
it disturbs the light different
temperatures different densities
so if you go from one density to the
other you end up bending
and so the light does this and then it
gets to your telescope
and it keeps changing and it blurs the
image
wow it's so you can see big objects not
so bad
but really small objects that are next
to each other
your two images can end up blurring into
one blob
so how do you get rid of that get above
the atmosphere
oh well i bet you isaac newton didn't do
that
except except he
drew the diagram that gave us our
understanding of what orbits are
oh my this guy you can't get away from
the genius of isaac newton i don't care
how you try
just saying so here's what you do you
put a telescope
into orbit ah all right now
you get all the benefits of a great uh
uh uh
reflecting telescope but now you don't
have the problem of the atmosphere
interfering with the image so now here's
my question
is there any equivalence to
atmospheric distortion in space is there
no not okay cause there's no atmosphere
no
i'm seeing the equivalent of some other
thing some other thing that would be the
equivalent of atmospheric distortion
no yeah okay okay
i'm cool with that the answer no okay
okay
so what we have is the
urge to do what we were doing on the
ground but from space to get better
images
all right so it turns out
the universe is talking to us not only
with visible light but with other forms
of light
okay like that you can't see really so
there's visible light coming to us
right and we thought that was everything
because our eyes why wouldn't your
why wouldn't your eyes see everything
there is why would my eyes lie to me
exactly exactly exactly this is what i'm
saying this is what it is
methods and tools of science have
revealed it's not just visible light
red orange yellow green blue violet of
the rainbow there is
ultraviolet x-rays gamma rays radio
waves infrared
microwaves all we've heard of all of
these yeah because we've they
we exploit them in everyday life so all
of these bands of light
are talking to us right through
different kinds of objects in the
universe
so if you want to talk to the universe
you want the universe to talk to you you
need a telescope that specializes
in each of those bands of light so each
one is like a dialect
yes right i like that that's kind of
cool a dialect of the language of the
universe
right hello governor all right
so it's clear that like the first of
these telescopes you think about would
be like a visible light telescope
so the first of the big telescopes in
space was the famous hubble space
telescope
all right you know how big that was no
size of a greyhound bus
for real yes wow yes and it was designed
exactly to fit in the payload
of the space shuttle right because then
the space shuttle can take it up
and and it could service and go back to
it and fix it
any problems it had and it did have some
early problems that we went up and fixed
with subsequent astronaut missions but
it's seeing and it's speaking in visible
light
edwin hubble hubble's the hubble
telescope
right specialize in visible light okay
and also
ultraviolet ultraviolet as well okay
cool okay because ultraviolet gets
trapped by
you're blocked by the atmosphere that's
what the ozone layer is for exactly
all right so got that one done okay okay
well we got more bands calling to us yes
we do okay so
the hubble telescope sees everything
that you
would see and then some with your eyes
how about the other bands of light
there's a telescope named after a guy
named named lyman spitzer
who was a professor of mine oh really
yeah princeton cool yeah yeah
and they sent up that telescope that
specializes in
infrared nice okay then we wanted to
open up the x-ray band
of the sky okay all right so there's a
telescope named after a famous
astrophysicist okay named subrahmanyan
chandrasekhar
okay okay and so we shortened all that
to just chandra oh thank god okay
so this chandra x-ray telescope and that
specializes in things in the universe
that give us x-rays just in x-rays you
know what one of them is what
black holes right on not they actually
don't come out of the black hole they
come out of the vicinity of the black
hole that's okay
and so that is that found monster black
holes in the universe
it's very cool nice this is without
x-rays you would not even know to look
for
black you couldn't do black hole you
couldn't even find those things okay i'm
not done yet oh my goodness okay
all right what else what else we have so
gamma rays don't make it down they get
blocked by
by atmospheric particles so there's a
compton gamma-ray telescope up there
arthur compton was an american physicist
okay and so all these are named after
physicists does the gamma-ray telescope
turn into
the hulk because that would be
i'm not authorized to divulge that
that's a state secret from what's the
name of that organization in the
in the movie uh it's a shield secret
okay cool so
so here we have did i list all four so
we have the hubble telescope right
visible light
uh spitzer telescope infrared right
compton
uh gamma rays and chandra x-rays x-rays
so these are the great observatories
that are orbiting the earth well what's
all the talk about webb and the james
webb
i'm talking about the camera oh okay
slow down
right don't slow down okay so now hubble
we we milked that puppy yeah it's been
up since the early 90s wow
and so yeah we got 30 years of really
good data off of that thing
in fact the hubble telescope may be the
most successful scientific instrument
there ever was lisa 16
000 research papers came from it
nice from 4 000 research scientists
wow it's it's it's likely the most
productive scientific instrument there
ever was how do you
at a multinational collaborations as
well so there's a committee of your
peers
called the telescope allocation
committee every big telescope has one of
these
okay okay and there's several people on
it and they read your proposal
and decide whether or not they will
allocate the time you ask for
interesting these great observatories
were huge windows opened
to the dialects to use your phrase of
the cosmos as they spoke to us
notice there were no radio telescopes in
that group
right because radio waves come right
through the atmosphere and we get them
untouched unimpeded they're big enough
so that these turbulent the turbulence
in the atmosphere in fact
you can use a radio telescope in a with
clouds right
okay in the daytime right so not all
bands of light are susceptible to what
the atmosphere would do to us
that's that's one of my favorite stories
it's about the cosmic background
radiation yes in fact that's microwaves
microwaves
so it's cause the big bang is talking to
us in microwaves and we have microwave
telescopes
on earth's surface right uh that work
great for that
so now we're kind of done with the
hubble
it's still doing some work but it's not
like groundbreaking like when it was
first launched okay so we have the next
generation
of the hubble space telescope okay and
used to be called the
ngst the next generation
okay and then we find somebody named
after james webb
right who's not a scientist i think the
first telescope was not named after a
scientist wow
but he was head of nasa while we were
going to the moon wow
that's a that's that's a pretty big deal
yeah it's a big deal so
the james webb space telescope scheduled
to be launched
in 2021 it's been delayed because it's
like
it's unique design and engineering you
don't pull that stuff off the shelf no
okay in fact the telescope is so large
it doesn't fit in the fairing
of the spaceship that's going to launch
it right so they have to take the mirror
and fold it up like the petals of a
flower
okay then the thing gets launched
deployed and then it unfurls
nice into their mirror some brilliant
engineering
concepts to make this thing happen but
that sounds dangerous this is
tuned to observe galaxies being born
at the beginning of time wow it is tuned
precisely for that and it can observe
other things
all right you can look deep inside so
it's tuned for infrared
to make that happen and it's got a huge
collecting area so
uh it can look deep inside of gas clouds
because infrared can penetrate
clouds and by the way that's not
something
unusual to people's awareness because
it's still hot on a cloudy day no
no i'm joking okay um when it's foggy
out
you're not supposed to use your brights
right because they're very blue blue
scatters into clouds and then it looks
like a movie screen a movie screen right
so you use your
regular lights but if you had fog lights
it's like they're like amber
and there you have it okay and they'll
punch right through the cloud
deep red lights would punch through even
better infrared the cloud's not even
there that's right it's transparent
to infrared so you take it infrared
pointed at clouds in the universe you
see deep down in
you could see the formation of brand new
stars and planets
yeah so here's just an interesting
thought different
materials are transparent to different
bands of light
right all right so there's a wall here
we're surrounded by
six sides floor ceiling and four walls
that's because visible light doesn't
penetrate these walls
right okay but i can open my curtains
light goes straight through
there's a window there right window is
transparent to visible light
your cell phone works in here why
because microwaves pass through the
ceiling right
different things are completely
transparent to different bands of light
it's you're right it's like laser
surgery they use different
or to get to different different depths
with your body within the body that's
correct
so it's it's just when we think of
something as opaque
it's only opaque for a particular band
of light and not other bands of light
see that's the cool thing about science
something is true
but then if you look a little deeper or
a little farther
it's it's conditionally it's conditional
correct true yeah
that's right there are no absolute
truths right that's right
there's like this is true for this but
but not for that there's
something else going on over here yeah
and here it's kind of like that but a
little different over here
right and there you have the entire
electromagnetic spectrum
serving the curiosity of cosmic
scientists which we call astrophysicists
as we decode the nature of the universe
i'm done here i chuck do your thing good
stuff
good stuff of course it's really
expensive to get video of telescopes
in space you think it was easy to get
this
well how about this and the james webb
space telescope
it isn't even in space yet but we can
still show you this clip
how storyblocks storyblocks video gives
you studio quality 4k
stock video without blowing your budget
we use it as star talk
and with our unlimited plan we can find
a video for just about
anything here's a donkey head to
storyblocks.com
start talk and sign up now audio
video photos templates whatever you need
storyblocks has it all we even used some
of their clips in this video
check out the link in the description to
learn more about storyblocks video
what's a donkey doing
we're done here as always keep looking
[Music]
up